[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOPHIA YANG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Sophia, product
manager from Google Cloud.
I'm here today to tell you
about Cloud Asset Inventory.
We all know by bringing
workload to Cloud,
you're benefiting from its
scalability, high performance,
secureness, and cost efficiency.
Yet at the same time, admins,
especially platform admins,
security admins, are facing
never-before-seen challenges
that were brought in by the
large quantity of resources
and data that can be easily
created by developers.
In fact, enterprises have
millions of resources
running on Google Cloud today.
So how can you see
all the things you
have on Cloud at the same time?
How can you keep an
eye on all the changes
as they happen so you
don't miss a threat?
How do you answer questions that
seem simple but are actually
challenging, like how many
VMs do I have in my org?
Who can change my
billing accounts?
Or what service account keys
that are older than 60 days?
I'm very excited
to introduce you
to Cloud Asset Inventory,
that aim to solve all
of these challenges for you.
As you can see here,
Cloud Asset Inventory
is a fully managed
metadata service.
So let's first address
the elephant in the room--
what is an asset?
An asset can be a resource,
like a VM instance, a BigQuery
table.
It can also be a policy,
like IAM policy, org policy.
It can also be VM
runtime information,
like system updates.
So now let's talk
about metadata.
Metadata here means the
configuration of an asset, not
the actual [INAUDIBLE] content.
For example, it is about
the name, the size,
creation time for the disk,
but not the files that
are written on the disks.
It offers many
inventory services
on your entire GCP and
Anthos environment, which
makes it truly a one-stop shop.
So you don't need to
go to Compute Engine
to find all your VMs and
then go to Cloud Storage
to see all your
buckets, for example.
And what is more
convenient than that,
it works at the organization,
folder, and the project level,
with fine-grained
IAM policy controls.
So regardless of your
permission level,
you can always take
full advantage of it.
Lastly, you can get up to 35
days of full change history
from Cloud Asset Inventory.
Now let's dive deeper
into the features.
First and foremost,
you can get a snapshot
of your entire inventory.
You can use either the
Export or the List service.
The difference is that Export is
a long-running operation, which
will export your data to
either a Cloud Storage
Bucket or a BigQuery table,
which makes it easier for you
to directly query and
analyze data later.
List API works just
like any other List API,
except it supports a timestamp,
where all the data will
be included in the standard
HTTP response in case
you don't want to deal
with a storage location.
You can also get a
full change history
by either using the UI or
API, which I'll demo later.
Now, after getting
full visibility
for your entire
inventory plus history,
we also offer a real-time
notification feature for you
to easily achieve
continuous monitoring.
It allows you to monitor assets,
and will send a Pub/Sub message
when change occurs.
You can define your criteria
as a name, as a type,
or by org, folder, and project.
You can even use CEL condition.
By the way, CEL is the
expression language
created by Google.
For example, you can say, notify
me as soon as any of our rules
got changed in my
org, or notify me
only if IAM policy is changed
to be open, or one of the VMs
deleted.
Here's an example scenario.
An admin wants to
monitor and get
notified when a Gmail account
is added to an IAM policy.
You first define your
condition in a real-time feed
using the code shown below.
Now if a malicious user
adds his own Gmail account
into the policy,
Cloud Asset Inventory
will trigger a Cloud
Pub/Sub message right to you
in real-time.
From there, you can define
all remediation actions.
For example, you can
write a Cloud Function
to roll back the change or send
an email to project owners.
The real-time
monitoring capability,
especially the conditions
supported through CEL,
ensures that you won't
miss any important changes,
and also filters out
the noises so you
can stay focused and
keep your costs low.
OK, now.
If you're one of the
policy admins or privacy
admins who have to be
on top of access grants,
take care of access
certificate, and keep track
of all the changes
across a whole org,
you will be really excited to
learn a powerful tool offered
by Cloud Asset Inventory--
IAM Policy Analyzer.
In a nutshell, it does deep and
thorough analysis on policies
and related resources to help
you answer the question, who
can access what and why?
For example, what
service accounts
can access my Buckets that
contain sensitive data,
or what access does this
terminated employee still have?
So what makes the tool powerful?
Let me show you with
an actual example.
Who can change my
firewall rules?
This is one of the top
questions admin need
to answer and keep track to.
Well, it turns out you have
to peel through many layers
to actually get to
the full picture,
starting from the "who" part.
"Who" can be a user, a group,
or even a service account.
In the case of group, there can
be multiple layers of groups,
which we call nested groups.
In case of a service
account, there
can also be multiple
layers of service accounts
that can impersonate
one another.
Policy Analyzer can handle
all of the above to give you
a complete picture
on the "who" part.
Now let's look at what's needed
for changing a firewall rule.
Turns out three permissions--
create, update, or delete--
can all make changes in
firewalls in some ways.
Policy Analyzer is capable
of mapping IAM rules
to permissions for both
curated roles and custom roles.
At last, let's look
at the last part
of the question,
project A. We all
know IAM policies
can be inherited,
which requires you to not
only look at IAM policy
through our client
project A here,
but also trace up along the
hierarchy to the folders
and to the orgs above to
make sure all of the policies
are analyzed.
Luckily, Policy
Analyzer analyzes
resource and the policy
hierarchy as well.
It also analyzes IAM
conditions and exports results
to Cloud Storage Buckets
or BigQuery table.
So here you go.
You can see how much work
the Policy Analyzer does
for you behind
the scene in order
to provide a truly complete
and comprehensive answer on who
can access what and why.
Now it's the demo time.
As I mentioned earlier,
let's take a quick look
at the Cloud Asset
Inventory Developer Console.
The Cloud Asset Inventory
Developer Console
is located under the
IAM and Admin tab.
First you can use
a tag on the top
to switch between org, folder,
or project that you would
like to see your assets at.
Once landed on the
landing page, you
will see an Overview
tab with automatically
pre-populated dashboards for
your deployment insights;
also resource and policy tabs
for details about assets.
The first geograph shows you
how your zonal and regional
resources are located
across the globe.
You can also get to
a table view of it.
The next one shows how
your VM instance counts
have been changing over time.
And the next view shows
you the resource counts
by services and asset types.
You can also use the
predefined filters
on the left to
focus only on assets
that you are interested
in, like VM instances.
As you can see, I
have 17, and they all
live in a US Central region.
Click anywhere on
the dashboard--
it will take you to the
corresponding resource IAM
Policy tab.
You can see here all the
filter options are carried over
from the graph setting
before, so let's uncheck them.
Let's assume I want to search
for certain VM instances.
So I can first check
on the asset type here.
And then I will further
refine my search results
by typing the search
term into the search bar,
like name contains
the instance and label
key contains color group.
And here are my results.
I can also search by directly
typing in certain asset
attribute values, like a
[INAUDIBLE] IP, as that's
what I found on
the internet and I
want to locate which VM it is.
And here you go.
I found my VM.
I can then click on the
instance to see the Detail page.
You can see the
high-level summary first.
Also, if Compute Engine
VM Manager is enabled,
you can see the runtime
information as well,
like OS version, kernel,
running or stopped.
You can go to the
Change History tab
to see the full change
history up to 35 days.
You can see here all
the timestamp shows
ones that had a metadata change,
and I can choose two timestamps
to compare the differences.
In this case, I can see that
a label, color group pink,
was removed between the
two versions, as well
as some other change.
Next, you can go to
the Full Metadata tab
for all the details,
like description, disk,
service account, et cetera.
And lastly, you can
see the IAM policy
that's attached to the
resource in the IAM Policy tab.
That is all for today, and
we encourage all of you
to try it out.
Check out the documentation
product pages down below.
And we're looking forward
to hearing from all of you.
Thank you very
much for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]